je me dis que jamais je ne reparlerai
plus de ça parce que plus que la maladie
cette stigmatisation cette exclusion est
destructrice
alors avec les progrès de la médecine on
a tendance à oublier que vivre avec le
sida est toujours un calvaire quotidien
qui peut toucher n'importe qui vous en
êtes l'incarnation ancienne championne
de France d'escrime maire de deux
enfants ex directrice générale du groupe
thomas Cook vous avez réussi votre vie
professionnelle et votre vie familiale
et pourtant vous étiez porteuse du virus
du sida alors vous racontez votre
histoire dans un livre intitulé un mal
qui ne se dit pas publié chez Robert
Laffont on en parle à 20h
[Musique]
à nous faire gagner rebonsoir vous êtes
né à Dijon le 28 décembre 1972 votre
père ancien militaire devenu maître
d'escrime élève ses enfants dans la
culture de l'effort et votre mère
employé de poste était l'inverse de son
mari est un peu baba cool écolo bio quoi
un peu
alors à l'école c'est extrêmement
précoce sur le plan intellectuel et
physique ce qui fait qu'au collège vous
lié avec une bande de jeunes qui ont
entre 3 et 6 ans de plus que vous à
l'adolescence vous opposez à votre père
sur les horaires de sortie vous fumez
vous flirter
disons que en tant qu'enfant précoce on
a envie d'avoir un autre statut que
celui lié à son âge donc on aime bien
provoquer si on nous reconnaît pas ce
statut donc moi effectivement j'ai pu
être dans cette provocation puisqu'on me
renvoyait tout le temps ma catégorie
d'âge à laquelle j'avais pas
l'impression d'appartenir
le seul moyen de communication que vous
ayez avec votre père c'est l'esprit en
fait en effet puisque mon père et mon et
mon entraîneur et c'est un lieu où il
m'éprouve beaucoup où je comprends qu'il
n'est pas tout à fait d'accord avec mon
comportement mais le moyen de me
l'exprimer ça c'est dur le sport sculpte
votre corps pour faire de vous une jeune
femme désirable qui découvre son pouvoir
de séduction sur les hommes et à 14 ans
donc précocement vous rencontrez une
nouvelle bande de jeunes très déjanté
vous devenez la petite amie de l'un des
chefs de cette bande toujours dans
l'idée de provoquer votre père oui et
puis je trouve que c'est intéressant de
tester comme ça des émotions fortes la
recherche d'émotion forte
effectivement j'ai fréquenté une bande
dont un des petits caïdes étaient
héroïne Oman voilà alors évidemment il
est très dévasté par la drogue vous
découvrez qu'il est qu'il a des crises
de manque épouvantables
vous décidez de mettre fin à cette
relation mais vous ne le savez pas
encore il est déjà trop tard cette
relation n'aura que très peu durée
environ six mois et quand je vois que
c'est assez tragique et très triste qui
se passe dans ce milieu moi je me
regarde parce que ça n'est pas ce que je
veux moi je veux rire je veux vivre en
juin 1988 vous avez 15 ans votre gynéco
s'étonne de mycose à répétition et elle
vous prescrit des examens et le 21 juin
1988 votre gynéco vous convoque donc
avec votre mère mais elle demande à vous
voir seul et là elle vous dit vous êtes
porteuse du virus du sida qui vous a
donc été transmis par ce garçon héroïne
Oman il te choque est terrible moment
d'une violence inouïe
oui parce qu'on est donc en 1988 contre
c'est rien de cette maladie que je pour
ma part je la connais à peine on sait
juste qu'on en meurt très vite sur la
route du retour vous êtes terrorisé par
la confrontation avec votre père vous
dites j'étais coupable du malheur que
j'introduisais dans la famille
oui parce que là je ramenais quelque
chose d'extrêmement dur à la fois sur
les connotations de cette maladie mais
tout simplement leur fille allait mourir
et finalement c'était ça qui
m'attristait le plus c'était la douleur
de mes parents parce que leur fille
allait mourir alors c'est finalement
votre mère qui annoncera la terrible
nouvelle à votre père aucune réaction
rien vous dites juste un silence
assourdissant qui va durer 23 ans
oui c'est installé un silence de mort
vous dites je n'en ai plus jamais
reparlé avec mes parents je n'ai jamais
parlé directement avec mon père jusqu'à
ce livre
de ma pathologie et de ce que ça avait
voulu dire sur toute ma vie
alors là vous décidez de vous battre
extraordinaire quelques heures après le
diagnostic vous faites 8 km de footing
dans les bois oui c'est vrai c'est
vraiment le soir même exceptionnel voilà
moi j'ai basculé du côté de la vie tout
de suite et quelque part mes parents
n'ont rien changé certes un silence
c'était installé il y a rien eu
d'explicite mais on a continué à vivre
comme si de rien n'était la
séropositivité devient chez vous un
moteur en fait j'ai rien fait de ma vie
j'ai 15 ans j'ai rien fait de ma vie je
perds rien je c'est juste que je vais
peut-être pas vivre longtemps mais je
suis sûr d'une chose c'est que ces
années là elles sont pleines de vie
voilà
alors en 1989 un an après le diagnostic
vous devenez championne de France DP par
équipe
et vos coéquipières ne savent rien c'est
never explain
non effectivement je pense qu'elles
auront appris avec ce livre alors vous
mettez en place une véritable entreprise
de dissimulation pour apparaître comme
la parfaite jeune femme ambitieuse
sportive pourtant vous allez à l'hôpital
une fois par semaine personne ne sait
rien
alors j'en parlais une fois vous partez
aux États-Unis dans une famille
d'accueil et quand vous l'annoncez à vos
autres en fait il réagissent très très
mal il me parle d'un ami à eux qui est à
l'hôpital et qui est en train de mourir
du SIDA et se disent la petite frenchie
elle comprend rien ce qu'on raconte donc
il me demande si je sais ce que c'est le
VIH donc je dis que j'ai le VIH et le
lendemain j'ai repris l'avion pour la
France
et c'est cet épisode qui fera que cette
fois-ci définitivement je me dis que
jamais je ne reparlerai plus de ça parce
que plus que la maladie
cette stigmatisation cette exclusion est
destructrice
encore plus profond après ça alors après
le bac faites une classe préparatoire
HEC toujours aussi brillante toujours
aussi belle toujours aussi sportive vous
finissez par douter du diagnostic
jusqu'au jour où votre taux de CD
passe sous le seuil fatidique de 500 et
là on doit vous mettre sous AZT et je le
refuse vous refusez la dégradation
physique qui est entraînée par le
produit et du haut de vos 18 ans vous
envoyez balader les perfusions les
contrôles et laser quoi moi je suis dans
la vie je ne souffre pas en revanche
quand je vais à l'hôpital je vois les
c'est un roi quand même à l'hôpital sur
le suivi VIH à cette époque ils ont les
joues creuses ils sont gris ils sont
très fatigués je n'aurais pas pu faire
mes études en terminale je vais arriver
en classe préparatoire et je dis
peut-être que je ne vais pas vivre
longtemps mais les années que je vais
vivre je vais bien les vivre
alors vous bossez comme une malade vous
passez vos diplômes vous réussissez et
c'est très beau ce que dit je voulais
que mes parents ressentent la fierté de
mon parcours et pas la honte de ma
maladie
mes parents je crois
n'ont jamais eu honte de moi mais quand
on n'arrive pas à parler de quelque
chose que ça renvoie un certain nombre
de
conception sociale qui les gênait être
certainement et on pourrait parler de
moi dans des termes de réalisation
différents de simplement elle a bien
lutté mais bon elle s'est éteinte
alors
là vous faites une carrière exemplaire
vous finirez directrice générale de
Thomas Cook en France bravo et
parallèlement malgré 25 pilules par jour
à partir du moment où vous décidez vous
soigner vous dissimulez votre maladie
pendant 15 ans dont 13 ans de
trithérapie mais
les dos sont très fortes et les effets
secondaires sont quand même là c'est
terrible vous dites le matin bon vous
commencez par vous vider complètement
ensuite vous prenez votre voiture pour
aller bosser vous avez des douleurs
intenables dans la voiture mais vous
donnez le change quoi vous vous arrivez
au bureau voilà vous êtes là vous
souriez vous bossez quoi que c'est tant
qu'on arrive à le faire
ça donne de l'énergie on se dit
je l'ai enfoncé et on est reparti pour
une journée voilà alors quand je dis
bien quand on arrive à le faire
alors quand vous êtes un peu crevé vous
dites oui je suis stressé en ce moment
quand vous êtes un peu orange parce
qu'il y a un traitement qui vous donne
un teint un peu orangé vous dites c'est
des UV qui m'ont rendu orange enfin vous
êtes formidable parce que chaque fois
vous trouvez le truc quoi alors sur le
plan amoureux c'est pas facile parce que
bah il faut annoncer la couleur la
première fois donc vous rencontrez un
homme plus âgé que vous de neuf ans vous
vous mariez mais ça ne dure que quelques
années en fait avec lui il m'épaulera
beaucoup parce qu'il m'aimera beaucoup
et que se sentir aimé quand on peut
transmettre la mort et qu'on peut pas
avoir d'enfants c'est quelque chose qui
qui aide mais effectivement nos chemins
un jour vont diverger le deuxième homme
deviendra le père de vos enfants Marie
et Pierre alors faites des enfants en
fait quand les enfants naissent ils sont
sérop les traite tout de suite c'est ça
non oui parce que en fait la
séropositivité c'est le ce sont les
anticorps dans OVH on va dire et comme
la mer transmet ses anticorps aux
enfants quelque part ils sont au sens
propre séropositif et les anticorps de
la maman vont disparaître peu à peu et
donc ils vont devenir séronégatif sauf
s'ils étaient contaminés auquel cas qui
développerait des anticorps mais qui te
seraient les leurs donc nous devons
attendre le bout de ce processus où les
anticorps de la maman vont disparaître
pour être sûr que les enfants sont
séronégatifs et ça dure assez longtemps
l'attente est de combien de temps pour
savoir que les enfants ne sont pas
contaminés on va dire qu'au bout de
quatre mois
on sait que on tient le bon bout c'est
flippant quand même non c'est quatre
mois
ils vont très bien
alors en 2010 22 ans après le diagnostic
vous êtes au sommet de votre carrière
vous travaillez 75 heures par semaine
vous courrez 10 km le dimanche et là
vous ressentez quand même une grosse
fatigue et à l'issue d'une longue
réflexion vous décidez de tout révéler
donc parce que le phénomène de déni
positif je l'appelle comme ça ne va pas
marcher là tu dis non c'est pas là bas
si c'est là et t'as pas le choix c'est
biologique t'as pas le choix et donc
j'écris au départ j'écris pour moi je me
raconte je reviens sur mon histoire pour
essayer de l'accepter les réactions sont
exceptionnelles votre PDG il est
admiratif et vos amis ont des réactions
extrêmement compassionnelles j'ai
effectivement les les regards sont
plutôt extrêmement bienveillants
extrêmement sympa aujourd'hui vous êtes
conseil en fait oui aujourd'hui
j'interviens comme indépendante et puis
pour pour un tour opérateur qui
s'appelle voyageur du monde et comment
ça va là
alors 40000 personnes en France
ignorent qu'elles sont porteuses du
virus du sida donc faites-vous dépister
maintenant il y a des tests extrêmement
rapides et lisibles le premier décembre
c'est la journée du sida et si là dessus
que porteraction des organisations voilà
et ça monte aussi qu'on sous-estime en
général dans ces maladies la force de
l'esprit on parle de choses
psychosomatiques mais je pense que
l'esprit quand il veut vivre quand il a
la bourre de la vie ou l'amour de
l'amour je crois que il peut jouer un
rôle très très important et il y a même
des cas où on a vu que des maladies
réputées irrémédiable ont pu être sauvés
par l'amour de quelqu'un ou de la
personne soi-même je trouve ça très beau
ce que vous avez fait vous êtes un
exemple voilà et nous sommes contenus
vous écoutant tout à l'heure et
justement là-dessus je pensais à une
phrase c'est drôle parce qu'elle m'est
revenue comme ça qui est au Mémorial de
la déportation à Paris et qui dit le
choix que chacun faisait de sa vie était
authentique parce qu'il se faisait en
présence de la mort il parlait de ses
résistants qui risquaient leur peau tous
les jours qui avait 20 ans
qui dit si tu ne cherches pas
l'inespérée tu ne le trouveras pas ah ça
c'est une belle femme alors ça
où est-ce que je trouve génial c'est
qu'il y a aucun moment un discours de de
victimisation et ça c'est formidable il
y a des gens qui sont capables de se
plaindre quand ils se cassent un ongle
et voilà et moi j'adore voilà super
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu